I'm going to read you a bedtime story
it's called good night Internet in a
small pink bedroom there was an iPhone
and a text saying long a phone case of
Harry Styles bought at the mall and
there were Pinterest boards with lyrics
from Lord in fun makeup tips for cherry
red lips pictures of the fan triple
filtered on Instagram Lululemon pants in
a cup of tea and a bowl of pasta that's
also gluten free a French Bulldog with
his own tumblr blog a frozen DVD and a
super hot selfie a set of gel nose and a
sweater from an urban outfitter sale
goon I crapped up goodnight shut up
goodnight Starbucks vanilla cake pop
goodnight Netflix
goodnight selfie sticks goodnight creepy
tinder match goodnight
Benedict Cumberbatch goodnight Taylor
Swift
goodnight Beyonce gif goodnight ariana
grande good night pumpkin spice latte
goodnight snapchat good night grumpy cat
goodnight candy crush and good night
Sephora makeup brush hmm good night to
my Bey and good night Lana Del Rey good
night Olivia Pope good night Leslie
Knope
good night followers good night friends
good night all my favorite internet
trends goodnight laptop power down with
care good night internet users
everywhere
you know my heart